okay hi everyone for people who are
joining this live stream we are
continuing to talk about uh template
reactions
and supposedly we're talking about
chemistry but actually we have a number
of people here because we're really
talking about graph rewriting
and uh chemistry is just an instance of
graph rewriting that happens to apply to
things that really exist in the world
and it's also related i think to things
about pattern about um
pattern to pattern rules and things like
this
so let's try to remember um can we
remind ourselves where we were before
um
[Music]
we were talking about how to represent
the um dummy elements of molecules the
you know the functional groups that are
often written as r and r prime and so on
now i had some notes from last time was
that was is it down here or
or not
from last time about um
i had a bunch of those notes where i had
found examples of um
uh template reactions that other people
had written down i think we should have
had those for this that's in um
um
that was from april 14th let me try and
use those
okay here these were our examples r r
prime our double prime all these kinds
of things right
right yes
yes okay so
do we think we've
i mean so what we had discovered there
was that there is this slightly funky
notation
um
but that fundamentally
there are
um
yeah go ahead we're going to say please
go on have you made further progress
go ahead
so i have not made uh very much progress
here i mean to mainly remove the stuff
about atom map numbers goes to to
whatnot um but at the i feel like uh uh
we're at a pretty
we need to to nail down exactly what
input forms we
we accept before i can uh really make
more pro progress and we need to nail
that down so i can yeah i know we need
to do it now and jason and i had various
discussion afterwards and i am actually
a little bit concerned with this
suggestion of ah underbar underbar
because it loses the information which
are it is it is the same r but not in
the center of our underbar it is the
same r in the sense of lower case are
under uppercase oh
lowercase s underbar uppercase r and
you know like i feel like we didn't get
this right the last time
okay explain that i mean you're saying
look the thing that's the earth is not
the same there are different arts there
are they look the same but different
instances of it okay so we must account
of them
independently why is it michael that we
always end up with this epistemological
whatever ontological
these
your point is just because this is an r
prime these are actually different atoms
here
yes
which one which one is there on the
right hand side
is lost in the r
but is preserved with the index okay but
so the bizarre thing that you're
pointing out is that
the two functional groups
might be they most might both be and i'm
going to make up chemistry i don't know
you know hydroxyls or something
uh you know they might both be ohs or
something like that but but your point
is it's a different oxygen atom and a
different hydrogen atom even though
the
the
template of the radical is the same
that's not quite my point that's 50 of
it the other 50 is that in
and it's not visible in your right hand
notebook
that there is an index on them and the
index is what matters they are not
interchangeable like if you would
isotope one take one of them then you
would run into a trouble
i understand i understand because
there's an actual carbon atom and you're
saying
that actual quantum mechanics be damned
that actual carbon atom winds up in a
particular place on the right hand side
of the reaction exactly exactly
that's why just having an
underbar on the left hand side
is under specifying the problem compared
with having an index
okay
can we understand
okay for expressions
oh my gosh i mean
this doesn't matter because there's no
conservation law we can if with our
underpants left side we can have five
hours on the right side without trouble
there's a lot of stuff you can do in a
regular express
normal uh wolf and language expression
with patterns a lot like it's a very
uh i don't need to tell you that
right but but so you're saying when it's
physicalized and there's actually an
atom
in the physical sense of an atom
boy
and you know what else is confusing and
confusing to me is in our physics
project right atoms of space also can be
replicated like
uh
unlike physical atoms
so i'm sorry that was a that was a side
comment for
nick and people who are into that stuff
um
go ahead i mean well
so i uh let's see so just to back up
just a little bit i if you go over to
the notebook on the left and scroll up
uh uh just a touch i've put
two basic uh uh input form i mean well
so there's three input forms and none of
them has the atom map number goes to
this
in the first form
you have
two a list of pattern objects goes to a
list of patterns and then you specify
the mapping with an association as a
second part
and i think that and that and that way
of doing it is a part number
based
is that correct i mean that one one
means the left-hand side of the reaction
i i don't quite understand now what is
this this is atom one
of reactant one yeah right because we've
already numbering the atoms here for the
bond specifications
yes now let me understand something else
in in our graph data structure this is
really a question for charles or
somebody else
um
we have the possibility of saying graph
of vertex comma edges right vertices
comma edges
but the edges refer to vertices by the
explicit names that the vertices are
given in the vertex list not by their
indices in the vertex list is that a
correct statement
um yes
okay so we don't have a pattern
i think that the question is not quite
quite sensible
because it's an atomic object so
without having applied an extractor the
question makes no operational sense all
right fine fine
i mean i i'm i mean the thing that we're
doing here so what we're seeing here is
we've got a list of atoms here
and we're referring to those atoms by
their positions now presumably we could
and maybe you support this maybe you
don't yet we could have in a molecule
pattern we could have this be an
association
that list of atoms there if that was an
association we could name the atoms with
us but for the purposes of the bonds and
for these purposes here and that might
be convenient
so so one goes or the
lowercase string c goes to uppercase
string c
for example but i mean let's say and
again maybe maybe this is just not
something people do
and i mean i could imagine something
where we say here an association and we
say you know
center
goes to sea
and then you know uh r1 goes to o
r2 goes to
um o and then here
we would say you know center
you know r1 etc
yes absolutely that would be very
convenient the only um
uh the the the reason we didn't go that
way is i mean just that let's see when
you go to then combine uh molecules or
break them apart do you keep those uh
associations or do you not i mean uh
when you create a molecule from a smile
well okay that that that's that welcome
to the world of graphs right we've got
the same exact issue with graphs
when you
so in graphs if you do a graph union
we're using
the names of the
vertices to decide what to union with
what
right in this case
one of the things that would happen is
what if there are two you know you're
combining a molecule that has an atom
labeled the center
with another molecule which also has an
atom label with center well that's the
same thing
as combining two associations and there
are a variety of different ways to do
that
can anybody comment on what the most
sensible way to do it in this case would
be
um in uh graph disjoint union it first
calls uh graph free number i think is
the function to uh renumber all the
vertices
uh and the edges
isn't that the next graph that gives you
a renumber yes yes it calls index graph
that's what it does
and then it can do the
uh
union without losing anything
because it increments the index from uh
for each graph that's the input so that
there's no overlap
by the way does index graph have an
option to determine what the first index
is
charles that's its second argument
second argument okay very nice
the um
okay but but so then here
so you definitely could imagine uh
entering the first argument of a
molecule as an association but that is
not okay fine but i'm just trying to
conceptually understand what's going on
here so so but most of the time
we are
sort of atoms have positions atoms have
indices those are the indices that we're
referring to here with the bonds
and in this case here
we are describing the reaction i think
this is a sensible way to do it i i have
to say i think this is a because
among other things that would allow you
to take that object there presumably and
that object becomes
some kind of um
i mean that's telling you the mapping
it's going to tell you the mapping of
every atom to every other atom
although sometimes as you've told me
before atoms can get lost
right if the user wants them if the user
wants to uh to discard the the unneeded
parts
right
but so
go ahead and and while not in the same
meaning structural this is exactly what
we do for
multi-stranded biosequences where we
have strand strand and then we have the
indices take base 12 from stand four
connect with
from strength 19 right i remember yes
and and that's done in biosequence
does how how do we represent a composite
biosequence
is this uh
usually we provide a list of uh
biosequences of the basic pipeline dna
or peptide in the first argument
okay and then we have a second argument
which is the mappings
the band that will be the bunch actually
the
okay
but so in this case where there's bond
bond
that is a list of
um
that's that's a list
let me just understand that that is a
hybrid strands
um
okay so now where does it say okay
so here
that means
that the the the a on here
yes
i'm i'm confused
to the u
of the second one so the pressure is
done
but now if i had a great big zippered
you know whatever it is a great big
thing with with connections all down it
would i have a single bond with a big
long list of of hydrogen
you know these hydrogen bond connections
or what would i have here no what what
we the design we decided on is that we
would have to enumerate each of the
ones i think there's an example
somewhere down below
one of the one of the
large mods
so women so you're saying
that
in a single bond here
i'm a little bit confused about this
actually base pair what is the base pair
yes
and there's no i understand that's
bonding
two elements two bases in a base pair
yeah but the design was that each body
separate you cannot uh there's no
distinct bonds inside it's a design
which was decided but wait a minute so
separate base pairs
rep
correspond to different bonds in the
list is that correct
[Music]
but what's this what's that creature
there
with the four things in it
is that some i don't understand this at
all
yeah so the first
so in the first component the second
base which is a is connected to the
fourth element of the first component
which is your t
that's why you want to which is indexes
one two and one four so this is a bond
within that first
strand is that correct yes right
and so what does this mean here
that's that's because this is uh what we
call an uh in inside bond representation
in here the the bond is put inside the
biosequence within hybrid strand the the
one before that is the external bond
representation so those are equivalent
uh ways to look at look at things
because there are operations that are
easier when the band is within the
component as opposed to
being outside the components
those are supposed to be equivalent
presentations
so here's a question i mean a bond
is this relationship between atoms in a
static molecule
in some sense in space-time
these things here
are similar kinds of they're kind of
like bonds but in space-time
does that make any sense
a bond is a spatial slice right of you
know you've got two atoms and maybe
they're at um you know super high
frequency they're exchanging electrons
or something if i'm not if i'm
understanding anything about this
chemistry which i might not be but um
you can think of maybe that way
but but but you're but what you're
imagining for a bond is you're freezing
it you're looking
at
you're ignoring time and you're saying
spatially these two things are being
connected by this thing that's bouncing
backwards and forwards in time okay now
our reaction happens
and if we looked at the space-time
diagram of where those atoms wind up in
the reaction we would see that the atoms
you know move from one place to another
in
they move in space time there's a
there's a space time there's a world
line for each each atom
and so i'm just trying to understand the
analogy i mean in a sense
maybe not quite like you could literally
imagine two two say h2s together
parallel aligned and now you flip the
bonds so they wouldn't have to move to
still flip the bonds
fair enough
but i think the thing you're trying to
capture here
is
which atom winds up being which which
atom of the product
right which atom of this right initial
state ends up at which atom of the final
state
and that to me
is kind of like a space-time bond or am
i completely confused
i think it's mostly time
space can be ignored for it i think for
basically a purpose
basically it's like it's a before and
after situation after the reaction
happens
the atoms may or may not be connected
anymore
no no i understand that i understand it
but what i'm saying is the concept of a
bond
is
and maybe i'm confused here but but
somehow
i'm just seeing this as being kind of
the
this idea of a bond which we're
representing here
i mean
here's here's the question i'm trying to
ask
these arrow notation may be the right
thing but i could also imagine
a kind of um
uh what would you name
when you say this atom in the initial
state goes to this atom in the final
state
what would you name the relationship
between those atoms what is the
relationship between those atoms what's
that called in chemistry
conservation of mass usually because we
understand that's the that's the
phenomenon but what i'm asking is
is you know you say there is a chemical
reaction
okay
um
and there must be
because i'm learning this analogy
between particle physics and chemistry
there must be exchange reactions
where
this is kind of a joke that it's that it
should be possible to infer something
about chemistry from particle physics
but where you know there is an atom that
sits on one molecule and then in the
reaction which is exchanged with an atom
that you know that the atoms in two
places and somehow they can be exchanged
in the reaction is that true
yeah and but i don't know that there's
necessarily a uh um
that that
you tend to think of it in the in the
terms of
looking at the before and after
and uh identifying the relationship
between those two atoms which you can i
mean you think uh these are the same
atom like they are um
that's that's what you think when you're
uh at least in learning about these
things but wait a minute when you
exchange the atoms if they're fermions
for example it matters
or am i confused well so i guess i was
thinking that you were exchanging
non-equivalent atoms that uh you had
like one guy had a chloride
no i'm sorry
is it the case that you can exchange two
identical carbon atoms and that you can
recognize that you know carbon atom
number one went to position two carbon
atom number two went to position one
i mean only if you usually you ta so
let's see they do exchange atoms um like
they i assume that is
but do you care about that would you
represent that here or would you not
represent that here
i don't think that you would
so you would just pretend that those
were identical carbons
i mean unless you were do you're
specifically studying isotopically
building experiments then you usually
wouldn't
yeah and isotopic labeling is important
no i understand that but i mean when we
write down when we have a template
reaction some standard template reaction
you know
in in truth if somebody had done an
isotopically labeled version of that
reaction they would know whether those
carbons exchanged
but are we going to record that or not
it often doesn't get recorded unless
there's a need to understanding in depth
uh the
mechanism
yeah so often times if
you end up with the right product
and that product is
you it just we just it gets ignored
okay fine but i'm just asking the
database that we're going to build up of
template reactions
we are not going to care about that
probably unless somebody happens to have
an isotopically labeled unless somebody
happens to have derived one of these
reactions in an isotopically labeled way
well let's see
i intend to to model biosynthesis using
labeled isotopes isotopically labeled
reactants and follow their
course through a series of reactions to
see where they end up not just
position wise the ratio chemistry but
also the stereochemistry i mean that's
what i did my graduate work on and i'd
really like to be able to turn that into
a computational machine
so we could apply it in a general way
to study
the biosynthesis
okay so so you would like to have our
template reactions actually take account
of so we would end up with
a mapping here where the right left and
right hand sides are both carbon atoms
and um well i mean in all cases here
i'm so confused with this in all cases
here
the atom type on the left hand side is
the same as the atom type on the right
hand side correct yes
that'll be the case
and so we
didn't make it
go ahead well i mean so uh so it's let's
see so we keep even though those these
carbon atoms we might think of them as
equivalent and when you just want the
products back
you lose the uh the mapping number like
you lose the history of it um but we do
need this mapping here in order to do
the stitching up so that
the carbon that was labeled number three
on the left
it had some dangling um
it was attached to some parts of the
molecule that were not part of the
template and so they get carried along
and so this these mapping numbers are
what allow us to carry the things along
and there's no stereochemistry
information that you need you just need
the mapping you just need this atom goes
to this other atom there's no
go ahead we do uh need in general uh
stereo like so in general we carry the
stereo over from the the reactants to
the to the products like what you feed
in gets carried over we need to
expand molecule pattern
to account for uh stereo so that
we can then have reactions that change
stereo but we
don't have that at the moment
the way it'll work uh there's an option
for molecules that specifies uh
stereochemistry and so we'll be adding
that into molecule pattern
okay but does that affect these
transformations the stereochemistry i
mean can one of these involve twisting
something that's that like this that
atom has certain bonds on it
and
in this
side could those bonds be twisted or
something
yes so so you can definitely write these
template reactions to do things that
would not necessarily uh be physical
like if you write uh that you know you
had a carbon atom over here that with
things arranged around it in a specific
uh stereochemistry spatial way
and then it gets brought over into the
products and things get completely
rearranged because you took the trouble
to write them out that way um and it
might not correspond to like an
elementary step in a reaction
okay
that's the result of several steps right
jason that's how i get in a mechanism
yeah
and stereochemistry can also be
generated
de novo
especially in ring forming reactions
okay
rings can only twist a certain way and
that because the other way would result
in something very sturdy and unstable
okay so look this design seems like it
is the least crazy of the things we've
talked about i'm not sure if this should
be an association or just a list here
i kind of think it should just be a list
jason brought up one strong argument for
the association you don't make the
mistakes by having
and left side key twice because you can
only
use it once yeah so i that occurred but
it doesn't stop you from using the same
um
keys on the right-hand side yes and so
both need to be checked uh i i i would
just i think it's a hack i i would i
don't know if other people have an
opinion about this but i think it should
just be a list i don't think it's a i
don't think the meaning is right for it
to be an association okay okay
now that's um that's
good and okay so then the the reaction
here
okay so let's just understand the form
here so we've got
a list of molecules arrow a list of
molecules
and then here we have in a sense
the transpose of that where we say atom
goes to atom
here we've got molecules goes to
molecules and this is essentially the
the um you know
atom by atom version of this it's the
transpose of this thing here we've got a
list of atoms going to a list of atoms
and here we've got the list of
individual atom transformations
am i right yes
sure
okay
okay i mean it's kind of like a sparse
form of a permutation matrix
yes
and the way we're referring to the atoms
is always
which molecule number
in the molecule pattern
by the way i assume that in this
left-hand side we could have just a p a
plane molecule here not a molecule
pattern
or am i confused
so
the question then would be uh um
do we
so if you put in a molecule of uh um
ethane does it match only
pure ethane like so does it match c2h6
or does it match um
any c2 and so i think it would have to
match just the first and so it would be
let's let's give an analogy
okay with strings
that you know if we do a string
transformation that says you know a a b
goes to blah
that string transformation in string
replace is
that substring anywhere in the string
as opposed to
the a whole string replace
which we could also do by anchoring
things in the string pattern right but
in this case
i mean you're saying in in this case a
molecule pattern means
this is a subpart of a molecule with all
kinds of you know things hanging off it
whereas molecule would be it's that
particular molecule
yes correct
yeah
i would imagine
that that's what we've been assuming
all along
okay i mean that really matters in these
reactions right i mean it yeah
too
yeah you might want a reaction where one
of the parts is a specific molecule it
has to be that and only that
okay so let me understand when you write
this thing here
how does that get written out in these
terms
what are these are things how are they
how are they specified are they just
i'm confused so in a molecule pattern
you would write either underscore or uh
the string with an asterisk
r we have do not have a defined semantic
meaning to r at the moment because it
gets used in a lot of different
situations and not always following the
same convention so i haven't wanted to
so we've resisted i've resisted nailing
down exactly what we mean by our
okay
could we talk about this named chemical
template reaction and whether it should
be called chemical transformation
right so uh so i put a note at the top i
mean it's it's it could i think if it is
a an object that tran like acts to
transform lists of molecules and so i
thought maybe molecule transformation or
the chemical transformation would work
as well but the point being that
it uh it operates on a list rather than
necessarily just one although you would
have it could obviously take just one if
the
um and then normalizes
that one it takes one if it's some
molecule it's fully that that it's just
happens to be a single
uh you know
right a single connected thing on the
left goes to something else right
but in the general form is that it
transforms a list of things into a list
of things okay so chemical reaction
let's remind ourselves what that is
chemical reaction
would have the exact same form as this
oh this is the i i'm confused
go ahead so chemical reaction came out
in the previous version it takes a list
arrow list
um
and it but the the things inside the the
list can be a chemical formula or an
entity
um
and or um any of the uh so i understand
why is this a different function why
isn't this just chemical reaction
let's see so chemical reaction um
doesn't contain any transformation
information it's it allows you to just
write you can write a chemical reaction
with just the formulas um so
you you already know the reactants and
products explicitly you're not allowing
the machine to compute the products for
you
yeah they're definite already
so what
i mean i don't understand there isn't
that in this particular case here
you're saying that there's no reaction
apply for a chemical reaction that is a
chemical reaction just is what it is
with literals
right
yes
and also a chemical reaction let's see
so
you can you can put uh stoichiometric
coefficients in front of things two
waters and and such but
so either through the string inputs or
through uh an association
okay why do you not need stoichiometric
information here
because if you have three different
water uh molecules in your in your
template reaction then they are going to
end up in three distinct uh places on
the right hand side and so they need to
be have their own
um you must account for everybody where
they end up yes
i thought you didn't need to account for
things i thought things could just go
poof into the solvent and things like
that exactly if that's why we don't get
the reaction
but okay so so let's let's ignore water
let's say you you had
two glucose molecules that you were
sticking together to make a disaccharide
okay
you you can't say
two times glucose or two copies of
glucose goes into the reaction
because of the atom mapping and stuff
you've got to say which one is the the
one on the left and which is the one on
the right because the connection is made
between different atoms in them
okay
if it matters i mean if there were a
bunch of identical things like couldn't
you have something
where you have i don't know
um
making some mineral for example you
could have
you know three aluminums plus something
or other
plus two irons or something
goes to
whatever
right and and and in chemical reaction
the the
detailed arrangement of the atoms in the
reactants and the products is completely
ignored
whereas in
what we've been calling template
reaction reaction apply
that detail is paramount
oh my gosh this is a mess
sorry
no no it is it is complicated but it so
the the template reaction is useful for
when you want to
you want to create molecules that you
have you've never
you're not even aware of no i understand
i understand chemical reaction is a
literal unpatterned
trans you know
transformation now you could imagine
okay if there were spectators in a
chemical reaction i could imagine
something where you apply a chemical
reaction to some collection of molecules
that include some random spectator
molecules and it will pick out of you
know you've got i don't know what you
know
hydrochloric acid and sodium
i i don't know anything about chemistry
sodium hydroxide hydroxide is what
you're looking at yeah yeah yes that's
right and it likes a big fizzing thing
okay
but but you also happen to have some
random sodium chloride lying around
which
the chemical reaction does not pick up
because you only but you could perfectly
well imagine something where you've got
those spectators there
right and that would be an equilibrium
problem because you would have to worry
about the forward reaction between the
hcl and the sodium hydroxide and then
the sodium chloride reacting in the
other way that would be a different
container and
sort of a layer up above a template
reaction
but why isn't that a chemical reaction
why isn't that something where you've
got the chemical reaction between the
hydrochloric acid and the sodium
hydroxide
and then
um
you know and that's defining a chemical
reaction but nevertheless there's a
chemical i know what we call it a
chemical state
that contains what we could perfectly
well just define the stoichiometry of
you know something with some number of
sodium chloride molecules there and so
on
and then we could say i mean
okay what is the is there a version of a
sort of chemical state
onto which chemical reaction is applied
does that even make any sense isn't that
isn't that what limiting reagents and
things like that are all about of you
have to have
some number of this kind of asset this
kind of molecule to you know
isn't that i mean so i think chemical
solution is the thing that we want to we
want to uh
address next uh in the next so right now
we're
we're trying to do a chemical instance
where you can describe three grams of
sodium chloride or
or three grams of sodium chloride at 20
degrees c
but uh next will be chemical solution or
or a more general term would be chemical
mixture
um
but that mixture sounds much better than
chemical solution
right but there i mean
they're distinct and not the same right
i mean a solution is not a mixture is
that right jason no um
all solutions are mixed or all mixtures
are not solutions okay
then um yeah so a chemical there's a
definition i'm sorry the definition of a
solution is
that
there is some chemical
binding between or what does it mean
what what does what does solution mean
it has to do with their degree of mixing
right jason yeah
and in phases so you can change the
scale
right the salt and water you get one
collective phase whereas when you start
the mixture you have a solid sodium
chloride in liquid water
okay so there's spatial distinction in
one case whereas in the other case it is
spatially all mixed up
correct
yes so another if you have lumps of salt
in there
then you would still call that a mixture
although how on earth are we going to
represent that i mean don't you need to
know how big the lumps are and stuff
like this
well if you
that gets back to the equilibrium if you
have the amount and the um equilibrium
constant then you can compute all that
actually yeah
yeah we just wouldn't count the lumps of
that i don't know how did you compute i
mean no i don't know that we could
compute the size of a lot
that's right we couldn't compute the
size of the lumps but we could tell you
how much is it so if you have more salt
in the
in the mixture than could actually go
into solution
we could figure out what would be left
over how many grams how many bowls
we wouldn't be able to say that they
formed three balls of the size or two
squares of that size
i mean i honestly i don't think the i
think mixture unless it has some bizarre
chemical meaning where you know random
things are precipitated out of the
solution and things like that
the the i mean it seems like a much
well okay is it is it the case that
whenever you mix
okay if you mix chemicals together i
mean if i take xenon and krypton or
something
and i put them together in a in a box
is that a solution
what temperatures
they don't interact
what's that
what temperature
well i don't know but i mean the
temperature was not about
yeah solution right so if it if it's all
the way down to the molecules it counts
as a solution is that what you're saying
if it's ground all the way down to the
molecules it counts as a solution if
there are bigger lumps where you have
little pieces of one you know little
little regions spatial regions of one
type of molecule and another type of
molecule and it counts as a mixture is
that right
if those regions are actually a solid
phase
right well so i mean there's going to be
some kind of the word homogeneity is
going to come into the real definition
yeah i i don't understand if if if you
have a little oil and water for example
where there are droplets right not a
solution that's that's a loop it's a
mixture because you can distinguish the
oil in the water yeah right so the
solution means it's ground down to
individual molecules and every other
molecule could be a different molecule
so to speak whereas a
mixture is something where there are
bigger lumps of one kind of molecule
that the correct definition
it works for me yeah pretty much and a
lump could be a liquid droplet or it
could be
an amorphous solid or it could be a
crystalline solid
okay fine but it's it is it is something
which even though it might be quite
small it is something which can be in an
identifiable
it's an identifiable phase of that
material yes and you could physically
separate it
okay all right but anyway so what we've
got here is a chemical reaction
oh my gosh what is this
see a chemical reaction presumably we
have reaction constants and things like
that you know rate constants and things
like that that we might put into the
chemical reaction is that a true
statement absolutely uh
so the the the idea there would be to
extend it to have another argument that
would be an association which could take
um
things like rate constants
um
things like respect
temperature
right so uh reaction conditions um
agents or let's see or let's see
non-reacting species
well that's good so catalysts for
example
right where would that go
so in that association would be um but i
and i i don't know if cattle catalyst
covers all types of non-reacting species
i mean catalyst
has a specific meaning as in like speeds
up the reaction but um but they would
fall into that category and so
chemical reaction would take a an
association of
um annotations is what i like to think
of
okay fair enough but but but so okay
fine so it's chemical reaction and
that's distinct from
which is of particular molecules where
we know what the molecules are
right
yes
and potentially the left-hand side of a
chemical reaction is what you're calling
a solution
rather than
uh
let's see where you say reactants here
reactants may be given in this form okay
reactants to products so
this left hand side which is usually a
list
could also be a chemical solution with
certain percentages or something of the
different molecules is that right
yes when we when we introduce that uh
data that data type then yeah absolutely
that would be
what's the relationship between
okay reactant counts
so here
i'm confused
if we say two h2os and three you don't
describe that in the documentation up
here growl growl it appears down here
but it is not described up here
well so
so like
sorry i'm sorry it is it's right here
excuse me yeah no i mean i've i'm guilty
of
uh
it sounded like me so i was willing to
believe it
right okay well anyway it is there
although it might be nice to show that
as a table but okay so then here
so this
when you say
one zinc hydroxide and one hydrogen
chloride
i could as well put that in a chemical
solution is that right
i think here you would want to use
chemical instance not a
solution why
why because it's because it's going to
react or what
i'm confused is chemical solution have
to be something that is non-reacting
what's the difference between the
left-hand side of a chemical reaction
and the
chemical solution
do you know the solvent
well i think we should say chemical
mixture because solution
solvent so i would think that when we
have a chemical mixture as an object
that
you could definitely
put it in any place where you would put
a list of uh
chemical objects you mean or an
associate but this in the list of
chemicals here are they of unknown
concentration or are they equal
concentration in that case
the concentration doesn't matter here
because the chemical reaction goes in
terms of numbers of particles so you can
write it in you know you need three
waters plus four or something else to
make five of the thing on the other side
so technically you're working in moles
individual moles or molecules yeah i
understand it in in this form here where
you've just got a list of chemicals
doesn't it matter that there are twice
as many waters as there are something
else's
and you're not you're not giving that
information here
right i mean uh so that's it i would i
essentially call counts on that to turn
it into the to the other
form oh i see so so in other words if
there were two waters you actually have
to have
waters listed twice
in that list of chemicals
yes
so that's the individual you need to
make this documentation better but
that's the individual molecules that are
going to be involved in the reaction
and what happens
maybe i'm
like these chemical formulas for
minerals and things where you have
fractional numbers of atoms there
is that am i just being confused is that
just a probabilistic thing can you you
can't represent that here no
even with that second form
right and i mean even um let's see so
the fractional coefficients i think i
feel like those are usually like in a
unit cell
that's that's fractional occupancy
where
in in some parts
that you've got
different
i'm expressing myself terribly
the fractional occupancy means that
in some unit cells it's one type of atom
and in other unit cells it's a different
type of atom usually it's different
metals like magnesium and and uh
okay all right fine
all right let's come back again barium
complete reaction thing
okay so i think i more or less
understand chemical reaction
um
but there is it
go ahead well so there's a
futurized dock page for template
reaction that has some sub values that i
might want to get your eyes on
okay
you really like template reaction i just
don't like it because it doesn't talk
about molecules and it doesn't talk
about and i worry that it's i mean it's
just such a weird
you know we so we got template reaction
and temp and reaction apply which just
seems very weird
well if we actually go ahead well i'm
sorry i i was just going to say if you
go with
reaction transformation or
chemical transformation would it feel
natural to have
such as a catalyst or temperature
requirements or heat or light
requirements in that
and chemical transformation
yes
because those things will accompany with
a template uh what will are part of a
reaction
what's wrong with that chemical
transformation what's wrong with having
conditions in a chemical transformation
no no i was just making sure that that
was okay so i don't think there's
problem with that but what would you
call the reaction apply thing if we
called that chemical transformation
uh the
proposed name somewhere
the
molecule transformation and apply
molecule transformation one of the
bullets in the left notebook okay
what about
chemical reaction class
i don't think that's right because it's
not the same kind of thing it's not a
class of chemical reactions it's a it's
a pattern
so if it were paul class i would really
want to test class membership and i
don't have that set up yet like
a chemical reaction a
an instance of this class but this is
difficult
yeah that's an implantation to joe but
what i'm claiming michael is that this
thing that you're currently calling
template reaction
is more like a pattern rule yes sure
no question
sure
right is there a reason why
like like reaction pattern i mean i
guess it's not literally a pattern but
but also maybe another problem to
mention with template reaction is that
template reaction doesn't integrate at
all with the template
template apply which if you do you know
template question mark template star
all but a couple of the the usages all
but like obscure boxes
are
work with template apply
that is very that is very true and i um
and so i also feel i i also feel hemmed
in by the word pattern so both template
and pattern have specific meanings in
in wolfram language and my molecule
pattern doesn't
fully
integrate with it and um
string pattern is also not fully
integrated
so i'd like reaction pattern
uh if that's not offensive
as opposed to chemical reaction pattern
i think we should stay away from
chemical
in this context because the chemical
could be an entity
it could be you know
we use it
in other ways and these patterns that
we're
talking about in the left-hand notebook
are
used with molecules specifically yes
well so you're suggesting reaction
pattern
or
i mean reaction pattern doesn't sound
terrible
and then what will be the apply version
absolutely
apply reaction pattern
okay
all right so that that i mean that seems
okay to me anybody object to those
so we'd be saying
uh
i mean reaction pattern actually seems
kind of nice to me
a reply reaction pattern would apply to
a list of would apply the same stuff
that you would say on the left hand side
of a chemical reaction that's a true
statement
could we get away with
just a ply reaction rather than apply
reaction pattern
possibly yes that would at least that
would um be easier in an education
environment
all right it's certainly so if you gave
it a
a chemical reaction so we could make it
take a chemical reaction and then just
require the arguments
to come in to be verbatim to match
the left-hand side of a chemical
reaction better be the thing that is the
second argument of an apply
exactly
okay
so
okay so then i don't understand why you
can't also
just like you've got a reaction pattern
why can't you also take a chemical
reaction
and apply it to the stuff that's on the
left hand side of a chemical reaction
right no so that's what i'm saying is
that if we if if we um
that so if the if it's reaction pattern
and apply reaction apply reaction now
that we're saying these it
it should be able to take a chemical
reaction as a
in addition to a reaction pattern
but yes not it won't do it's not
the things need to match verbatim they
need to match q not contains q whereas
exactly with exactly
right
okay
so
all right so let's let's see
um
so there's a couple of sub values that i
think are important um
mainly the matching the um
to be able to tell given a molecule is
this does this match any reactant
um boy
does it match uh specifically i'd like
to yeah i'd like to know which reaction
it matches
which reaction actually i mean the fact
is putting a bunch of sub values in here
rather than having a bunch more actual
functions i mean
i don't know
but they're very detailed yeah i know
they're very detailed so let's go
through these a bit so reactants
products
those are also supported in chemical
reaction correct
yes
reactance products and reactant counts
would be specific to chemical reaction
and not to the reaction pattern
because reaction pattern those are
distinct objects on the left-hand side
rather than countable
rate
okay
equation display
supported in reaction pattern
why not
um let's see making a chemical formula
for the things inside a chemical formula
generally won't represent the things
inside a a molecule pattern
most of it would just be star or
asterisk asterisk
um
no but we have those pictures on the on
in this thing here with with ours and
things
what's wrong with that
right okay so uh so re equation display
is i mean it's it's literally a row in
that case so it's not uh
but so this molecule pattern here you're
telling me i can put blanks on this is
that right yes
so i can put a blank there for example
yep
and that turned into a star in that
picture
right and i am interested in revamping
the like enhancing how we
visualize molecule patterns absolutely
well i mean what is that what does the
chemical literature have for that
generally that's where those r groups
show up
would be an r
so maybe what we want
is some kind of stylized r
maybe we want you know
an r with a with a colored background or
something
to indicate one of those
and if we did that perhaps i mean you
know with those r's and our primes and
all that kind of thing so what are we
doing with the numbers here
what are we doing with those mappings
why are we not
worrying about saying which oxygen you
know in this drawing here why oh that's
this business here
right
yeah the thought was at least that
highlighting was more
conveysive than or
informative not that not convisable and
more informative than tacking the
numbers onto the atomic symbol although
if you're watching it you need you need
something different
what was that if you're printing it it's
no good to have interactive highlighting
yeah yeah that's right
but yeah so i think we want an option
where you actually show the subscripts
yeah yeah
and so we kind of uh just assign them uh
um sequentially
that's what i would do yeah yeah
but i think
with what you're doing here
with that circle thing which needs still
needs to go through graphic design but
having that kind of circle thing as the
indicator of a pattern object and
putting an r inside it seems like a
reasonable way to handle that star thing
right i mean so the only uh
trouble i see i mean although maybe it's
not that big of a trouble but if you
have three underscores
do you represent miss three r's because
um
people are can be forgiven for getting
the impression that seeing three r's
that it means specifically they're the
same i understand i understand so okay
so what are the alternatives i mean
the um
okay if we wanted to go really exotic we
could have random colors in the
backgrounds
we could have ours but with a random
color in the background
where each distinct r gets its own
separate color
oh it would be hard to tell that
i have trouble distinguishing some
colors
yeah yeah well so does everybody but i
mean and it would give an indication
that they're not the same
in that case that's where we would use
the plains or numbering like r1r2 art
yeah and and
that's what you prefer then
yeah i think we need primes or numbers
the colors might be helpful
all right so this is an output form so
we can choose to if there's a single r
it's just a single r otherwise it's our
one or two r3
yeah and but okay so what about the
reaction uh where the r's are the same
so i mean you mean i see where you're
tracking so your point is that you've
got two different indices you've got the
index of the type of r it is and you've
got the index of which instance of a
given r it is
yes yes there is there is that also yeah
right that's right so what you're
basically telling me is that you have to
use primes that the the indices one two
three have to be which instance of the r
it is rather than which type of r it is
i'm making sense so we probably need to
yeah you're making
yeah so so there i mean there are going
to be cases where
like so when creating a molecule pattern
outside of a reaction
it you
the user could want to call something r1
r2 or r prime
and so that i would love to nail down a
syntax for them to be able to say so in
that case they could do atom underscore
and then
r group label goes to and then some
display form like r1 r prime
um my fancy font
you're saying atom of underscore
[Music]
is it really an atom it's isn't it a
functional group of some kind
well no i mean in this object it's an
atom
and it represents i mean and when you
draw them it's it's understood that i
mean in this
representation
we're
that r might stand for anything else but
in this representation it's just an art
like in that notebook that you have over
there those that it's
they're dummy atoms is what they're
tend to be referred to as yeah
label would be an a good
key to use there
yeah and when the r group is a
functional group like a nitro or a
phenyl or something like that we're
generally only interested in the atom
that's bound to the
the reacting part of the of the reaction
all the rest of it gets carried along
automatically and we don't
worry about specifying it
right so you're not worried about the
fact that you're calling it an atom even
though it's got a big tail hanging off
it
we haven't worried about it maybe we
should
we haven't we've got i mean we've got
plenty to worry about i think no i
understand that but i mean my question
is do you really want these pattern
objects to be called atoms in molecules
or should we call them instead something
different like whatever you're calling
them you know
you know
so internally i called him a query adam
uh
but uh i i've not tried to that sounds
really pushing that forward yeah and and
the other day
the other thing we have to keep track of
is if we have a bidentate r group as an
inorganic chemistry
where it's attached to
[Music]
through two different bonds to some
other part you know of the of the system
that's reacting
so how on earth do we represent that
well no i mean so in that case i mean if
you have an underscore in there and we
decide to label a single underscore with
an r
then if it has two bonds to it then it
would just show up that way
it wouldn't be
nothing special would need to be done
yeah the bond list would take care of
that
i think so in other words so it's it's a
faux atom
i don't like this this is going to bite
us somehow it's going to bite us in
stereochemistry it's going to bite us
somewhere
because you know an atom doesn't in and
of itself i mean it is you know okay it
has orbitals hanging out but it's it's
it doesn't have the same kind of stereo
you know 3d structure that some
you know functional group would have
so uh
i was going to ask how how would you
feel if instead of using the forcing the
head atom on the dummy atom we made a
dedicated head like dummy atom or query
atom as uh mentioned earlier well yeah
but i think that that's a i i think that
the atom thing is a hack
the thing is not an atom it is what what
is it officially called that are things
it called well no i i i it's not
officially called anything our so our
groups are kind of used
all over the place i don't think they're
colloquial their iupac doesn't define
them they're really just um fragments
that could have one molecule or or one
atom or multiple atoms or as you often
put it
a terminal vertex or a full subgraph
okay but but but
is in fact a molecule fragment
yes
yes
so i mean and another thing like so
you've got your main molecule that
you're looking at and it's got this r
attached to it on one side but then if
you
you will often find in the paper that r
is this other fragment and the point
where it was connected to the first
molecule you can label that with an r so
it's kind of in that way r can stand for
just a half formed bond an attachment
point
um okay let me make a generalized
comment here because i mean you know in
our effort of many years ago to sort of
you know computerize mathematics right
there were many conventions that people
had
of oh you can write you know d2x by dx
squared
right but we're not going to follow that
convention explicitly you know we're
just going to decide we have a
derivative and you can do it twice
so i i think you know as we try and
computerize chemistry so to speak we
have to be aware of the fact we're not
necessarily going to follow every
by hand notational thing that people use
fair absolutely yep yep so
i mean
but i think
it's bothering me this idea that we're
going to have an atom
i think it's a mistake i think if you
have an atom that is a blank it means a
single atom that can be any you know can
be anything
that's really that is what we're
matching though like so when you
when you match that against the when you
use it as a pattern and say where is
this
we when we return back like the the
mapping of the of that template into the
the molecule yes or of the pattern into
the molecule we only
give assign one vertex to
that i i i feel like it's right because
it's just that
the the piece of the molecule is an atom
there are stuff hanging
off of it but they can have they can
hang off on any other piece also and
they always get carried along
i see what you're saying so you're
claiming
that this pattern is sort of the
backbone
exactly
yeah the c represented is an atom a
single atom it has kind of things
attached to it but that's a different
story
fair enough
okay so then the thing that can be there
it can be alternatives it can be a blank
the naming of that blank is what you
were concerned about there
right and the naming that you're
proposing
go ahead right would be
so adam underscore and then
dummy adam label goes to and then they
could put in you know subscript
our
horrible name can't we come up with
something
so our group label or
adam label i think is wrong because we
know that's random because
that's rigorous it's awful long to type
though yeah
yes
we can maybe skip the molecule because
already it is within the coupled
molecules
well
could it just be a label
label those two no or is that two oh no
yeah um
so wait a minute this is what else is in
atom what other stuff is inside atom
so adam the first argument is your
atomic symbol or of the blank here and
then you uh list of rules you can tell
it uh the formal charge mass number
the um uh
okay there's a straight run count yeah
those are strings
well then why don't we just say
display name
i know that way we if you if you put in
display name
then it can then you could you know
change your random carbon to have
something you know to be a display name
that is a carbon with a red circle
around it or something
no that works for me
actually
is it
or label or something
would that be a tag i was it's not
really a name
yeah fine all right okay
then
what other examples do we have of this i
mean like like for example we have
vertex label as an option in graph
right so in graph you have like vertex
um
rendering function or something so if
you wanted the vertex to render as the
letter r even though the vertex is well
you just say that's expression you just
say vertex label and then you give but
is a question actually for charles or
anybody else is is
in the vertex list is there a way of
saying right in the vertex list that i
want this vertex to be uh you know its
actual name is foo
but it is to be displayed as a red bar
it's annotation
which you can give in the vertex list
yes
when when you create the graph
i see
so that's it but it's it's option that's
an option which is being added in an
annotation there
effectively yeah it ends up going into
the the vertex label list
right
it's just like vertex style
i think here what we need to do um
well okay so what should we call this
this is
atom label or no it isn't an atom
it's really um
so i would like uh display label
although i could also be happy with
display name
um display label seems better than
display name
okay we use label for vertex label
oh no no we don't vertex label is a
label outside of the vertex itself
yes
that's right i think it's display name
although michael seemed to have an
objection to display name
it seems
why why is it more unnamed than a label
for me it's a label not the name okay
tell me i the reason i'm saying it so
okay the question is
a label in a graph is something which is
shown
to describe the node but the node is
drawn
however the node is drawn and then it's
got a side label that says you know
you know a or something
right but the node itself is drawn as a
as a gray dot or something
and most of the labels that we have are
off
you know are off objects i see
and so is the atom label like atom label
is was added recently and i mean it's
exactly equivalent to vertex labels
so it's an off object
i had originally like within the group
proposed that you should just be able to
say what the atomic symbol is
like say atomic symbol goes to r
um but that that uh is not quite right
because that atomic symbol is something
that really means something and you
can't just say carbon has an atomic
symbol
it's more like we want a uh
an atom uh rendering function that's not
just label right it's also how you put
the uh how you put these connectors to
the rest i mean with one call i mean
what what kind of you said atom
underscore would use for r groups
i mean what what kind of index does it
do within useful bonds it's always one
i mean just wherever it shows up in the
animals right
and then the other thing is uh these are
conventions how to display them right
and nature is always superscript
never subsequent right but there's i
mean
for my research there's lots of
conventions i mean it would be like we
could pick one but uh there's other
reasons
look display name seems harmless here
absolutely
um
and i think then so a new symbol for
this yeah no no no no no no no no no no
it's a string it's one it's like it's
good
charge and so on good
um
all right i need to wrap up here but is
it was there anything else that we need
to
oh yeah you you were wanting to ask
about those um
uh weird
things right so they're very data
structure like they're uh like um in
that they are sub values that take
arguments
um okay what if i'm a fan of them
reacting
this is really deep in the entrails of
this particular
molecular goat
but it's needed for proper programmatic
dealing with the things
right
reaction match q returns to a molecule
matches any reactant in the reaction
i don't know i don't have a horror i'm
not horrified
excellent
um the reactant pattern majesty and
that's so freaking weird
yeah the alternative is that we have
dedicated functions
well i mean we can always go to that
yeah we can always go to something more
like that later i mean i i feel like
by the way does anybody know what
emerald is doing with these with
reactions do they have a representation
of these things
they do we
yeah but we've never seen details have
we jason
uh
no
well why don't you look at the
documentation it's online we can ask
them
um i think we're going to do a session
with the emerald folk uh
next hopefully hopefully early next week
um where we're actually going to do some
chemistry
hopefully like we're actually going to
you know do an hplc or what they uh yes
hopefully hopefully i mean we'll have to
get set up i think we need to get all
the account information and so on set up
maybe we'll send them a sample that we
can do this on
um and then maybe we can i don't i don't
know how real time it can be done yeah i
i had sent uh nathaniel uh
some stuff a little bit earlier today
about the diels-alder network that we've
been talking about and okay cool so you
think that's an under brian realistic
to um i mean is it plausible i mean
i don't have any sense of this how long
do those reactions take is it like
minutes or is it like yes they're very
fast some of them you know
no heat at all at room temperature and
and it's over very quickly
quantitatively
well what does very quickly mean does it
mean a minute or does it mean minutes
yeah
huh
and so so then it will have
produced whatever it's going to produce
and that just sits there and then you
can analyze it yeah yeah
wow i'm trying to get as much background
on these different things as i can to
know what what's feasible and what's not
okay okay and so then then you would
expect that i mean the analysis like an
hplc thing how long does that take
those will be longer
like hours or what uh
i mean i'm not sure yeah it's
hplc was new when i was still in the lab
and uh the things have probably changed
a lot brian would be able to give you a
much better idea of what contemporary
hplc is like
okay
but but i mean i i just don't i mean
like like
you know doing chromatography with
filter paper it takes like you know many
minutes oh yeah that does it takes
forever for the solvent to creep up
filter paper to do that separation
yeah but an hplc column is not filter
paper
no
no no
pressure is on your side yes yes
okay fair enough
the
um
yeah the hp is either high performance
or high pressure
depending on
what you're talking about
okay fair enough well okay so this will
be but but
it will be good if
you know
i mean you know in a perfect world right
just like we can take
uh you know
a 3d geometry and send it to a printer
it would be super cool to be able to
take chemistry and send it to
emerald
absolutely
i mean
and um
uh and a credit card
same with same with 3d printing right
well yeah that's true that's true i
think they restrict 3d printing your own
credit card
no no no no no no
that's a different subject altogether
very good jason very good
that's we have to um
yeah emerald no doubt has things where
if you give it a you know explosive
reaction they will try and detect that
yeah
sandbox mode
yeah but
okay it's more than emerald we have to
bring in you know sigma aldrich or
whatever to get starting materials and
so on
and can we reference that if we wanted
to reference the sigma aldrich um you
know do they have some do they use cast
numbers or what do they use
yeah they would use the catalog from
sigma aldrich
use the catalog numbers but but then can
we transform if if you have an entity a
chemical entity in our system can we get
the sigma aldrich catalog number
probably
i don't know if jason has it hooked up
but i i'm sure it's feasible
but so that's a reasonable api i mean
it's a reasonable thing to i mean
you know
if we're actually getting real here so
that we can actually start imagining you
know
i mean look if we can get the steel's
older thing to work then we can go all
the way from symbolic chemical reaction
to actual
you know measuring
those things and then it starts to
really matter that we can do things like
transform to a chemical catalog and so
on
yeah yeah i don't i don't know if
stephen is aware of this but sigma
outbreak also provides a custom
synthesis services so you ask them what
to make optionally how to how to make it
and they'll do it for you for
for a safety
yeah i'm sure that that's a very
different process i think that's a
that's presumably humans doing things
it would be it would be that was yeah
that used to be uh
aldrich's buyer catalog for some of that
stuff
right
um but yeah it's it and it wouldn't be
just run this reaction and tell me what
came out it's i you know please make
this
particular compound and they will figure
out what the appropriate starting
material is and reactions to use and try
to do it you know cost effectively so
they make a profit
right but that's surely an expensive and
long i mean that's that's very different
story from from what we're talking about
here where we it is
it is yeah
okay well very good all right anything
else that we need to cover right now
we're good just
just one two three against that remark
because i was reading your paper by this
recently so the
the detailed influence of
indistinguishability of the atoms in
chemical reaction is a very complicated
story and it's not fully understood
these days
and that has to do with this continual
measurement nonsense in chemistry okay
exactly it has to do with measurements
uh basically it's basically post born
oppenheim
yeah so just explain this to me because
i mean usually when you exchange you
know when you have fermions for example
you have a minus one phase when you have
you have a thing where the two fermions
are exchanged
there's a minus one phase but you're
telling me when two
fermionic atoms are exchanged there is
not a minus one phase in chemistry no i
think kinda like
even the meaning of
what did exchange here becomes much more
fuzzy in the environment around
i see it does the other things around
the other things around uh basically are
with respect to the two things like uh
apocalypse that measures the two things
hold on second so destructive
interference does it happen in chemistry
in other words if you did the chemical
two-slit experiment
where the carbon atom can either go that
way or that way
are you telling me that basically you
would not see
there's this question would you see
destructive interference with two
individual uh carbons definitely i think
has been even done with bucket balls
yeah
okay but that's not what i'm asking i'm
asking in those things
you're saying it will if they're
individual and they're not in they're
not bound to other things they're not
part of molecules you will see it but if
those sucky balls had trailing crud
because they were part of a molecule
you're saying you wouldn't see it
is that right
yes
and so
the the because in a sense
the trailing
tail of molecule
is a continual measurer yes exactly
i'd like to understand this better this
is telling one something about i mean
this idea of microscopic you know sort
of nanoperception measurement
is sort of interesting because that's i
mean that that is beginning to take
apart the monolithic concept of
measurement
i mean is that a fair
i mean in other words
by saying in chemistry
it is no longer the case that
i mean
okay no i think it is it it makes the
difference between what's
technically called the pre-measurement
where you get into an interfere an
intervention term between upper orders
in this system and this plus
prime plus two prime this is very easy
still on the
microscopic level if you have part of a
molecule in the rest but then there is
normally no no amplification in the
microscopic irreversible step
if you are at the intermediate
yeah if you're an individual atom
against a molecule so
yeah
right and
and i see but the point is
there isn't amplification but if you
have a chemical reaction you have a very
large number of molecules
you can then do
what is the analog then of i mean i
think i think that if you do this in
cold atoms with 12 in your little ball
and you let them come very carefully you
get all kinds of interference but if you
have it in a real environment where the
other ones come with collisions you
immediately go here and
become classical
hmm
this deserves further understanding
i mean i think
it's interesting i mean i think
and the decoherence time
is presumably comparable to the
collision times or what
in other words is it the case because
that is that is basically thermalization
very directly so i mean just like in a
measurement you say i'm going to do
amplification and when i do
amplification
i'm basically going to make this giant
cascade and i want that cascade to have
certain thermodynamic properties so that
i can you know
so it doesn't interfere with a different
version of the cascade in this case when
you're having actual molecules colliding
it's the most direct form of
thermalization you know
if i understand correctly uh yes and no
it depends now if your collisions are
elastic or inelastic
yeah but they're presumably elastic most
of the time i mean unless they're
reactions they're elastic collisions and
what's wrong with i mean elastic
collisions still lead to thermalization
no i think that's genetically
unfortunately not correct
really no why i mean they they they
randomize the momentum of the molecules
the momentum vectors
uh yes uh like this sufficiently many
but not with a few
how many do you need i don't know maybe
thousands or something like this
that is a very interesting claim
heavily related to this whole
sub-chemistry discussion that we've been
having
because you know that that relates to if
you have a little reaction network that
involves you know let's say it doesn't
thermalize for you know you've got this
ring of five reactions of five
collisions happening
you're claiming anyway more to be
understood we've got to wrap up here
this is like this persistent currents in
in called atoms
explain
like like like in a superconductor like
you can bring a bunch of atoms in the
state that will flow forever
sure
yeah
a bunch of atoms as opposed to electrons
you're saying yeah but they interact
through the electrons
okay and
why i see i said okay because it's a
single quantum state yes they're
claiming that that yes so even though
there are multiple
right the question is yeah i mean this
is a
yeah the question is how many
connections do you need to the outside
world
to okay anyway to what we thought about
a different time yep um that was that's
very interesting all right great stuff
talk to you all soon thanks